to me i stand with the sort of
defining documents of this country
which is all men are created equal
there's a basic humanity
and there's something
about tests of intelligence
just knowing that some people are
different like the science of
intelligence that shows that some people
are genetically
in some stable way across a lifetime
have a greater intelligence than others
makes people feel
like some people are better than others
and that makes them very uncomfortable
and i
maybe you can speak to that like
the fact that some people are more
intelligent than others in a way that's
um
cannot be compensated
through
education
through anything you do in life
um
what do we do with that
okay there's a lot there
we haven't really talked about the
genetics of it yet but you are
correct uh
in that it is my interpretation of of
the data
that genetics has a very important
influence on the g factor
and this is controversial we can talk
about it but if you think that genetics
the genes are deterministic are always
deterministic that leads to kind of the
worry that you expressed
but we know
now in the 21st century that many genes
are not deterministic that are
probabilistic
meaning they
their their uh
gene expression can be
uh influenced
now whether they're influenced only by
other biological variables uh or other
genetic variables or environmental or
cultural variables that's where the
controversy comes in
and we can come we can discuss that in
more detail
if you like but to go to the question
about better
people better
there's zero evidence
that
smart people
are better
with respect to
important aspects of life like honesty
even likability
i'm sure you know many very intelligent
people who are not terribly likable or
terribly kind or terribly honest
is there something to be said so one of
the things i've recently reread for the
second time
i guess that's what the word reread
means
uh
the rise and fall of the third reich uh
which is
i think the best telling of the rise and
fall of hitler
and one of the interesting things about
the people that
how should i say it
um
justified
or maybe propped up the ideas that
hitler put forward
is the fact that they were extremely
intelligent
they were in the intellectual class
they were
like it was obvious that they they
thought very deeply and rationally about
the world so what i would like to say is
one of the things that shows to me is
some of the worst atrocities in the
history of humanity have been committed
by very intelligent people
um so that that means that intelligence
doesn't make you a good person i wonder
if
um
you know there's a g factor for
intelligence i wonder if there's a g
factor for goodness
uh you know the nietzsche and uh good
and evil of course that's probably
harder to measure because it's such a
subjective thing what it means to be
good
and even the idea of evil is
a deeply uncomfortable thing because how
do we know
but it's independent whatever it is
it's independent of intelligence so i
agree with you about that but let me say
this i have also
asserted
my belief
that more intelligence is better than
less
doesn't mean more
intelligent people are better people
but all things being equal would you
like to be smarter or less smart so if i
had a pill i have two pills i said this
one will make you smarter this one will
make you dumber which one would you like
are there any circumstances under which
you would choose to be dumber
you